there are good boys and then there are
very good boys like these dogs here
they're searching for a scent that no
human can detect the scent of an
epileptic seizure we've long known that
dogs can detect seizures and humans in
some cases 45 minutes before they occur
that's one reason why organizations like
all impatient and France provide service
dogs for people with epilepsy and in
some cases this can prove life-saving it
might give people time to take
medication that could prevent or reduce
the severity of a seizure or move
somewhere safer where an injury is less
likely to occur incredible yes but
proven not until french researchers
teamed up with medical mutts a us-based
organization that trains seizure alert
dogs that marker they believed was a
scent that dogs can detect so in 2018
they set up an experiment first they
collected dozens of samples of breath
and sweat from people with different
forms of epilepsy some of them were
taken during or right after a seizure
while others were collected after
exercise or at rest then they
distributed them among seven different
steel containers in this room finally
they let out or they let in the dogs one
by one Casey Dodger Lana
Zoe Andrew walked into the room they
were trained to stop and stand still if
they think they detected the scent of a
seizure and if they were right they got
treat good dog to the researchers
excitement the canines excelled three of
the dogs Casey Dodger and Zoe sniffed
out the odor associated with seizure
with 100% accuracy
the two other pups Lana Andrew who had
less time to Train weren't quite as
accurate but they still correctly
identified two-thirds of the seizure
samples on their first try what makes
these results even more remarkable is
that the scent samples were from
different people and also produced by
different kinds of seizures and what
exactly is that marker made of here's
the thing we still don't know it's
likely that seizures trigger a change in
the body's electrical activity the
researchers say and those changes can
affect the composition of odor molecules
that we emit through our sweat breath
and likely urine
now whether people emit these odors
before a seizure in time to reduce its
worst effects is still in question and
it's not something that the researchers
tested but some experts claim that
people emit a specific group of odor
chemicals 15 to 45 minutes prior to
seizing which dogs can detect so what
exactly makes canines such smell
superstars it's their incredible noses
with as many as 300 million olfactory
receptors my dog's nose is up to 100,000
times stronger than our own that means
that they can detect a few scent
molecules among trillions of them
scientists are now trying to build
electronic noses that are just as
powerful the idea is that they too could
be used to sniff out disease
but for now a noses are nowhere near as
good as dogs and in some ways doesn't
that seem like a good thing
[Music]